uh we're going to be starting here
momentarily i just want to make sure
that all of you can hear
my microphone so please
inform me if there are any issues
uh prior to us beginning and we'll get
started
in a moment here okay
i am here with my dunder mifflin cup
so i am ready to go and my tea
all right good you can hear me good
all right then so this is going to be my
first refutation in quite some time
and i'm tending to this live because i
feel like uh
it doesn't need to be pre-recorded
and um
i wanted to actually get this done a
little sooner but unfortunately i've
been really busy uh my wife is still
recovering so i've been having to play
both mommy and daddy for the past couple
of days so i haven't had much time to
put this together
however i did finally get it done
and
we are going to start now so this
refutation
i'm going to explain what this
repetition is about who it's targeting
etc
and uh so let's go into that
okay
all right so
i'm actually going to be responding to a
thread
by a twitter user by the name of abu
topi
and also i'll be going after some of his
associates
now
many of you people don't know who this
person is and that's fine
but to give you some context as to the
purpose of this refutation
and why i would be targeting an
insignificant twitter user
it's because
um
well i have a number of reasons why so
first off i want to reveal a long time
plan to discredit me through false
allegations in order to undermine my
criticisms of daniel hakikoju and his
muslim skeptic team
and abu topi
and the others i'll be
dealing with
are sycophants and lackeys of daniel
and in fact
they have been coming after me
repeatedly
um
and quite severely for the past couple
of months since i revealed my refutation
against daniel and they've been doing
everything in their power to discredit
me without actually dealing with the
criticisms that i've put forth
and in fact there are some hints that
they're actually working with him as
well
that they may be part of the muslim
skeptic team
and i tend to reveal that as well later
okay
now
for some more context daniel actually
liked this particular thread
and
he also retweeted it so he also endorses
a lot of the accusations here
and so this is going to be killing two
birds with one stone not only am i going
to be dealing with abu topi and his
friends but also revealing the
dishonesty and lack of integrity of
daniel
as well even though i won't be
mentioning him that much throughout this
refutation
um
so let's continue
the second reason i want to show this to
you is to show a case study on the toxic
and anti-islamic nature of the
refutation culture currently infecting
our dawah so throughout this reputation
i'll be revealing dishonesty i'll be
revealing anti-islamic standards and
even beliefs that these people hold
because i know many of you have been
watching some of my streams in the past
and you'll see that i mention these
people in passing sometimes i mention
what i don't like about their
their methods etc
but
i often don't give you
like an actual example to see to witness
so this is going to be a case study for
you to see exactly what i've been
talking about all these months okay
and finally to prove why certain
individuals are in fact irrelevant and
should not be listened to now i know
many of you are probably telling me well
this guy's irrelevant he's just a troll
don't feed the trolls
and that's a very legitimate thing to
say however sometimes we have to go out
of the way to prove this to be the case
right to showcase why they're irrelevant
right
and i intend throughout this refutation
to showcase that
definitively and at the same time to
showcase why it's a bad idea for some of
these kids to get involved in the
refutation culture especially going
against somebody like me
so with that out of the way
let's get into it shall we
so here's the thread a response to the
lies of assad ali aka project andalus
they used to be my my former twitter
name when i had twitter and then i just
got rid of twitter because it's a
cesspool and you're going to see why in
a moment
so a response to the lies of assad ali
okay so let's start off shall we
so abu topi begins i recently i have
been informed that assad ali
ali but you know they want to
disassociate me from allah
so you know even though that's not their
right but anyways he goes on recently
i've been informed that assad ali has
repeatedly ranted on his live streams
about me and other individuals who have
criticized jaquin in the past i was then
sent this now deleted list of
allegations which i will now address and
the allegations were actually deleted
because the stream was deleted
after one of daniel's supporters went
and harassed my wife on facebook but
that's for another discussion
so
what is this particular thing he's
responding to
so in this response actually he skips
number one so let's go to number two he
says he's going to be responding to abu
topi at all have falsely accused me on
numerous occasions of working with cve
and being a traitor to this ummah even
going so far as to support haitim
safadeen who openly declares me in
monafic because of set of false
allegations
okay so here it is um
so the first claim here that he's going
to be responding to is me claiming that
he has falsely accused me on numerous
occasions of working with cv and cv is a
a program that was started by the united
states in 2011 that spies on muslims and
generally attacks and criminalizes
muslims for normative islamic behavior
attaching normative islamic behavior to
terrorism
okay and a lot of muslims have been
falsely accused of terrorism and have
been falsely uh criminalized and even uh
jailed for things they never did because
they happened to
you know
um
you know uh be
islamic okay so i don't agree with cve
at all in fact they've never worked with
cve we're going to see that in a moment
as well
and uh here i'm claiming that ebotope
has falsely accused me of working with
cve okay
so
let's start off with the first claim all
right
what does abu topi say in response to
this well he says
that
i have never stated you work with cve
rather you
legitimize it and support it and then he
goes on to say something else and we'll
get to that in a moment
he said so let me let me first emphasize
this he says i have never stated you
work with cve okay remember that he says
i have never
stated that you work with cve
all right so let's look at if this is
true or not so he's remember he's
falsely accusing me
of falsely accusing him of never of him
that i claim that he said that i work
with cve so he's saying this is false
he's never said this
okay well see there's this thing called
uh twitter search function right
so let's go to uh december 1st 2020
last year
assadullah's work with cve
is extensive
so here's ebutopie claiming that my work
with cve
is extensive
okay
let's go back a little further
november 30th
oh well probably because i came after
him for his role
in cve
right
let's keep going
leaked footage of yakin justifying their
work with cve and here's a picture of me
along with others
okay also apparently i work with lgbt
and i distort the quran in surah sunnah
right so other false allegations
slanderous allegations against me
okay when have i ever worked with lgbt
and destroying the quran in sunnah and
work with cve
okay
here's another one august 30th 2020
if you ever oppose his work
with cve in malaysia you must back daish
etc
right
so
apparently
abu topi has never claimed
that
i have worked for cve yet we have posts
that are only a couple of months old
where he openly states explicitly that i
have worked with cve
so no it is not a false allegation
when i accuse you abu toby of claiming
that i work with cve
because you have said explicitly
that i work
with cve
so
word of advice son if you're going to
incriminate somebody
don't incriminate yourself in the first
line of your argument
because right now you've just
discredited your entire thread
you've completely destroyed your
credibility in the very first line of
your thread
by falsely accusing me
of something that is true
right falsely accusing me
of falsely accusing you when it's not
it's not a false statement you clearly
said this about me
right so apparently
you're unashamed of lying
because it's very clear that this is
what you've accused me of over the
months
okay so no i did not lie about you i did
not slander you in fact you have
slandered me and now you're changing
your argument
to something else
now you're saying rather you legitimize
it and support it so this is what we
call the fallacy of hedging okay is when
somebody
changes their accusation to the claim
right and then what they do
is they act like that was what they
initially stated to begin with okay so
they changed the argument
you know right after the fact
so he goes on to say so we've already
debunked that part right that's easy
so
rather you legitimize it and support it
he goes on to say
you have repeatedly threatened and
reported muslims based off your own
assumptions that they were khalarij
now i've never
reported anyone because i thought they
were khaladj
i reported people because
they have
claimed to support isis
to a large extent
and uh advocated for violence
and uh or even claimed to be part of
isis itself
so um that's primarily where i have or
al-qaeda right so those are the people
i've actually gone after or reported
okay
so let's look at some of the evidence he
uses
so here's one of the things he gets from
my facebook any support for al-shabab
which is a terrorist organization
will be met with an immediate ban and
possible impossible reporting to the
authorities and possible reporting to
the authorities
so here i emphasize the word possible
okay because i don't just report people
randomly because they say oh i support
al-shabab and al-qaeda or isis in fact i
talk to people or i examine their
beliefs and their behaviors prior to
saying anything or even thinking about
reporting people
and ironically
some of the people that
abu topi faciliates with on twitter
you know have
openly expressed support at times for
these organizations to release their
actions
and i have never reported them at all
because you know generally i just think
they're stupid kids but that's besides
the point
so this is one thing so he says that i'm
reporting people because i said i will
possibly report you
to the authorities okay
so
i don't know how that support he goes on
to to show another thing
you uh so this guy named abu ma'ali
which i think who i believe was a
discord moderator on the muslim chat
discord okay
and um
he says you've repeatedly called people
isis supporters and caused them harm and
never publicly rectified your mistakes
don't bring up slander
so
this is an interesting post that abutope
is using as
evidence because
after 22nd of february when this was
posted i actually reached out to abu
mali to figure out why he had a problem
with me okay
and on the 23rd of that same month the
next very next day
i went to muslim chat and i publicly
apologized to abu muwali for something
that i did wrong sorry abu maali for
something that i did wrong and then i
even posted this very post in my own
discord it's still there
okay now it says deleted user because
it's my previous account but
and it should still be posted pinned in
muslim chat
right
now the what actually occurred before i
read all this
is that
i unintentionally
well i was trying to accuse somebody
else of something and i brought up this
guy's name alif ghani or so i said
afghani
and people from muslim chat assumed i
was talking about this guy abu mah ali
okay
and people started harassing abomali
because of my comments now at the time i
didn't realize and but eventually after
everything was explained to me and all
the things he went through as a result
of my accusations which i didn't intend
for him
i still came out and publicly apologized
to him
and then
okay and then i went out of my way to
pin this in my own server and i even
publicly apologized on behalf of my
staff who went after him
right so let's let's see here i'll read
it out to you
this is a message to clarify and rectify
an issue surrounding brother abdullah
ali al-afghani i seek to clear his name
of false allegations that he supports
the actions of behaviors of groups like
al-qaeda and isis or their affiliates
some time ago brother ali came to my
server to discuss some issues and was
promptly banned after a misunderstanding
between he and my staff i was informed
later that it was due to him supporting
extremism quote unquote when i came to
understand the situation i made a public
announcement and reprimanded those who
did so
that said i did not anticipate that any
further harm would come to him and was
recently informed that he had suffered a
great deal of harassment and stress as a
result of these actions on a particular
note was an incident that occurred last
november when i was discussing isis and
that conversation i mentioned in lf
ghani
i did not think anything of my mistakes
at the time and i sincerely believed i
had been referring to baghdadi but my
comments were misconstrued by some to
refer to brother abuma ali who happens
to go by al-afghani
still i did not think i have at the at
the repercussions of my statements nor
did i concern myself with the blowback
that he may receive from my error to be
honest i was quite apathetic
not until today did i realize how much
my words and the actions of some of my
staff have negatively affected him in
his reputation as such i seek to rectify
this by issuing a formal apology on
behalf of my staff and myself and
stating quite directly that his
reputation should no longer be tarnished
by my own inconsiderate behavior he has
attempted to reach out to me in private
but i had forgotten him either because i
didn't take it seriously or because i
didn't see that he was actually hurt by
all this either way the fault is mine
and mine alone
i ask for forgiveness for my actions and
pray abu mali is to be giving great
reward and favor by this dunya and most
of all by allah
so let me ask you a question here
why would you bring up this as evidence
when i actually rectified
anything with abu mahri right
and at the same time let me ask you a
question about topi would you or any of
those people you support like daniel or
haitham would they ever make a post like
this taking responsibility for their
actions would they ever
apologize openly like this could you
imagine anyone in this chat could you
imagine daniel anyone could actually
make a comment like an apology like this
that would be a miracle
i'm pretty sure judgment day would
follow if that were to happen
okay like
don't tell me
that i don't rectify my mistakes don't
try to produce evidence against me when
i went out of my own way even in my own
server
to humble myself to put myself down even
to take responsibility for other
people's actions even
okay when you guys don't even have the
conviction or the integrity to do any of
those things and it was ironic about
this too
what's really ironic about this
is that abu mahali actually liked your
thread
knowing
that i had apologized to him for this
very thing
that he was calling me out for
which shows you their lack of integrity
which shows you how juvenile and
petulant they are
is that they don't even recognize
when somebody has has lowered their wing
to them
that they're still willing to ridicule
and abuse them regardless of that
okay so interesting right
so let's continue shall we
he then goes on to show another picture
of me a brother well this is where i'm
saying you're a snitch for reporting and
arresting isis members that's stuck for
the law because i had
dealt with these sort of arguments in
the past
and then i say yes because it's a
greater sin to snitch than allowing
those people to blow up misogyny in
marketplaces
so i'm
calling these people out for what they
are
showcasing that they care more about
reporting people than they do about
these people killing our brothers and
sisters okay that was the point
so
now
here's where it gets really funny so abu
topi is accusing me of of supporting cve
uh he's accusing me of supporting cve
because i report people okay
but what's really interesting is that
abu topi does the very same thing that
he accuses others of doing
so let's look at this tweet now you'll
notice here that this tweet was deleted
by the tweet author however it was
written by abu topi himself remember
links are shown below so you can verify
this yourself
and albotope loves to delete things
especially when he finds out they
incriminate him so watch what happens in
the near future he's probably going to
delete a lot of the stuff that i'm
mentioning
so abu topi here
uh was accused of reporting a muslim
okay
and when he was responded to by vuitton
i don't know how to pronounce this guy's
name he said what's wrong with that the
guy responds and says you mean what's
wrong with reporting a muslim brother
who is minding his own business
and then abu topi goes on to justify his
reporting you mean what's wrong with
reporting a prominent daishi who openly
promotes joyman
so here abu topi is admitting to
reporting
isis supporters and affiliates
on twitter
reporting them to the authorities
okay
this was in january 27th of this year
right this was not that long ago
he even complains about people who took
fear him for doing this aren't you the
guy who may tuck fear of me for
reporting twitter accounts right
and he even encourages
muslims
he even encourages people to report
other muslims to the police so here he's
actually saying should give should give
them a taste of their own medicine and
report them to the police for harassment
he's actually encouraging
muslims to report other muslims
to the uk police department
okay
and here he's going after me
for reporting
other muslims
now what's even more interesting about
this is that i already know how he's
going to respond he's going to say well
no no no i don't report them to the
authorities
i report them
to twitter which is different see that's
different right and you're going to
expect this so i expected this response
right except there's a problem
you see if you go to twitter's blog in
they mention that they're working with
cve
and i quote we cooperate with law
enforcement entities when appropriate
then they're actually uh lauded by the
fbi
and then beginning in late 2013 our
global public policy team embarked upon
an ambitious outreach campaign attending
over 40 countering via countering
violent extremism events and training on
four continents we also attended
government convened summits on cve
hosted by the white house the australian
attorney general's department the uk
government the french prime minister the
european commission and the united
nations
so in other words abu topi
when you report people on twitter for
extremism
uh you're working with cve
or in the very least you justify and
support cve
so congratulations son i guess we should
call you abu snitch or abu fbi
right
i wonder what muslim chat would think of
this
or maybe hate himself a deem
right because he may took fear of me
for reporting people
i wonder if he'll make took fear of you
now
right
and here's some other stuff here
guidelines for law enforcement on
twitter's help page they talk about how
law enforcement works with them and how
to work with them
and that information is even used by
independent policy institutes the
information that's accumulated by
twitter on extremism here's a uh
brookings institute uh study
about
isis demographics on twitter abu cve
that's another good one has a ring to it
right
now he may say well i was ignorant of
this i didn't know i didn't know that
twitter was working with cve
really well who cares if you didn't know
let me say let me say it again who cares
if you didn't know who says you were who
you were ignorant anyway how do we know
because when other muslims come out and
say they were ignorant of something like
omar salehman who was ignorant of
libations you don't care
you in fact you mock him after the fact
i've seen you like tweets and stuff like
this where where he's they're mocking
omar soleiman for saying he was ignorant
of libations you don't care
so why should i give you the same
benefit of the doubt
i'm sorry abu cbe
but that's not going to happen today
okay
see you live by the sword you die by the
sword except in this case my sword is a
lot sharper
so after this
what's even more ironic after this abu
topi retweets this by zikat one
how can any muslim with gera for his
deen ever support the kuffar against a
single muslim
a muslim may be a rapist a murderer or a
thief but so long as they proclaim the
oneness of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
they will always be better than all the
kuffar on earth
he retweets this in response to kind of
try to hurt me a little bit more right
and this is interesting
because he's basically admitting himself
that he doesn't have gyra
because he's reporting muslims to the
kuffar
um
fascinating
but there's also something wrong with
this uh this whole mentality here uh
that i want to discuss here how can any
muslim with gyra for his deen ever
support the kuffar against a single
muslim
right and this is actually insulting to
the companions of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam the way that it's
written okay
and i bring up some hadith in support of
that malik related to me from yahaya bin
sayed that from
uh evan al-musa
dispute brought to him between a muslim
and a jew omar saw that the right belong
to the jew
and decided in his favor against the
muslim
and then it goes on okay
and he did this on the basis of justice
so you're saying
that because umar
supported the jew against a fellow
muslim
that he doesn't have giraffe for the
religion
for allah
let's continue
safwan reported from a number of
companions of the message of allah
sallallahu alaihi wasallam and the
authority of their fathers who were
relatives of each other the messenger of
allah said beware if anyone wrongs a
contracting man or diminishes his right
or forces him to work beyond his
capacity
or takes from him anything without his
consent i shall plead for him on the day
of judgment and this is under the
section in sunan
of the vimys okay so this is talking
about a kafir
or people of the book
so the prophet sallam said that any of
you
who goes against these people who
commits injustice against them i shall
plead for them on the day of judgment
against you
so you're saying that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam doesn't have
gyra
that's not for allah
that's stuff for allah this mentality is
so absurd and i've seen this mentality
especially in real life as well
especially in western countries right
that these individuals
they will not even report a fellow
muslim if that muslim has done something
against them
so for example if they found out that a
muslim like an imam or something has has
has molested or raped their own children
or their wife or their sisters they will
not say anything
they will not say anything because they
don't want to support the kuffar okay
for allah but they won't even do
anything else about it because
vigilantism is also haram right you
can't do anything so they won't do
anything
okay this is the sort of mentality here
that has developed
all right they are more concerned about
identity than they are about their
principles
all right
because islam is based on justice it's
not based on who's muslim who's kafir
it's based on justice
another hadith uh that's hassan in
sunnah
i asked the prophet salallahu oh
messenger of allah is it part of
tribalism
then a man loves his people the prophet
said no rather it is tribalism that he
supports his people in wrong doing
if your gira leads to injustice it's not
ghira it is not
do you understand
and the same thing this is
the prophet sallallahu alaihi whoever
supports his people and oppression is
like a camel that falls dead into a well
and is pulled out by its tail
and what's even more ironic about this
is that in march 20th 2021
abu toby said the following in a tweet
exposing sins does not matter when the
harm caused by the sin abuse is greater
than the harm from spreading the news of
the sin consider this if a robber enters
your house and starts taking your
property will you keep silent because we
hide his sin
and of course it's a rhetorical question
because he wants to answer no you will
not keep silent
but if it's a muslim will you keep
silent because if you go around saying
well a muslim robbed from me
then the authorities are going to get
involved are they not
so here you are asking people to reveal
a sin
right to reveal something a misdeed that
has occurred
so if a muslim rapes your your sister or
your mother or your child
you're claiming here that we shouldn't
hide this so what's going to happen if
you make that accusation
the authorities will be involved will
they not
will they not
you don't think too much do you kiddo
so let's continue
just to give you also some some
background here about hatham saif deen
who abu tupi follows
when he saw this comment on facebook he
actually accused me of being a munafiq
he used this uh ayat from his ayah from
the quran glad give titans to the
hypocrites that there is for them a
painful punishment so he's accusing me
of being monofic
and on his facebook page he notes the
same accusation he screenshots me and
and to let you know that he actually did
tuck fear me like took fear of me down
here you'll see on the far right hand
corner a comment by ibn fulan who says
may allah deal with apostates like him
and hath himself a dean like the comment
okay here's a more close-up of that
so i'm wondering when hathan's going to
start making tak fear of abu topi
if at all because abu toby supports them
so i doubt they will because
like i said identity is more important
to them than principles
so
let's continue here oh before we get
over here i'm going to explain this in a
moment i want to kind of digress for a
moment here
so what have we seen so far
well first off we've seen
explicit
explicit disregard for integrity and
honesty we've seen explicit lie
about me
uh that i falsely accuse somebody of
saying that i work for cv when in fact
he did say that okay
and he unashamedly lies and then he goes
on to showcase his own hypocrisy in the
matter
of supporting cve
okay he then goes on to showcase that
he doesn't actually have gyro for the
religion
and
it seems to me that this is a very this
is a frequent uh
behavior by these individuals engaged in
the refutation culture
it's not that they have double standards
please you're mistaking my argument if
you think that i'm saying that these
people have double standards no they
don't have double standards they don't
have any standards
because their version of islam is a
machiavellian version of islam it's
based more on post-modern identity
politics than it is about our principles
so for them it's an islam of convenience
right they're more concerned with
using islam for their identity rather
than using their identity for islam
okay
and that's why they don't they they
don't care about integrity they don't
care about
being consistent they don't care about
any of these things okay
and
he's probably wondering at this point
he's probably fuming actually
that it was probably a bad idea to go
against assadullah it was probably a bad
idea and you're right it was a bad idea
because i'm part of the old guard okay
i'm part of the old guard i'm part of
the guard of abdullah al-andalusi zara
forest
all right
all the old days before you guys came
along and took over twitter with all
your cancer
all right and other social media
platforms i'm part of the old guard who
still respects integrity and honor and
dignity
when giving dawah who thinks apologizing
is not a dishonorable thing to do
okay
who thinks that's a manly thing to do
all right we you're going against the
old guard right now
that is why this is so easy for me
okay
um because
it's not because i'm a genius it's
because you don't have any standards
so
now i want to move into something else
before getting into a second claim okay
and that is uh what they're actually
really angry about
and that is what i did in malaysia so
it's not just the whole thing about
reporting people right
but it's also about the fact that
of what i did in malaysia now what did i
do in malaysia some of you don't know
i've discussed it in other streams
before but i'll kind of go over it
briefly here
so while i was in malaysia i got my
master's degree in islamic philosophy
and then i started my phd in
sharia law okay
and what happened was that
i started to research about isis and
their tactics and stuff and i had a
personal incident in my life where a
friend of mine i knew his son
actually got caught at the border for
trying to join isis
so
um
that got me emotionally invested
personally invested in sort of trying to
deal with this issue because a lot of
youth were getting attracted to them for
some reason right so i started
researching them i started researching
the mentality of these people etc
and so during this time i was doing my
research i was starting to give lectures
at um
university of malaya et cetera right
and um
what occurred then was that i was
approached by the malaysian government
to give these same lectures to youth
across the country okay
and these lectures were primarily about
me
discussing the roots of terrorism and
this ideology that isis has right
and i wanted to try to convince a lot of
these young students that they should
not be attracted to this group that was
basically my only job at first right
and uh much of my um much of my research
was actually against cve in fact most of
my research can be found
on my ig series oh let's go back first
because i don't want to do that yet
um
where is my thing
okay i'll look at that later so anyways
uh that particular i'll discuss in a
moment so that particular picture you
saw was me giving a lecture
at uia islamic university of malaya
uh where i was doing an event hosted by
beyond the horizon
and there and i was giving a lecture
and the interesting thing about it was
that it was and i'll just read this here
so that you understand how much i'm
against cve okay
take note i even mentioned this in the
post take note that the organization is
sponsored by the united states
department of states by the us
government that said i am taking part in
this panel to spread awareness of the
roots of terrorism and extremism all the
while offering solutions in other words
as a us citizen i will not hold back my
criticisms of western ideology and
foreign policy as the primary culprits
of terrorism and extremism in the muslim
world
and then i go on to say i expect the
country i was born and raised in to
respect my right to speak freely in this
respect despite my allegiance being
solely for islam and my patriotism
solely for my now extinct andalusian
legacy
which ironically doesn't make me a
patriot at all please make dua that i am
successful in countering the mainstream
myths about terrorism extremism so i
went to this
panel that was actually hosted by
the united states government
and i bashed the heck out of the u.s
and the cve program
okay
so
let me ask you this question abu toby
oh by the way i was not invited back to
this after that let me ask you a
question about toby
and daniel all you guys would you go on
one of these and would you openly refute
them in their face knowing full well
that the security services will be
coming after you after that
that they will be looking into you after
that would you do that heck you can even
show your face
online on twitter
so what makes you think that that what
i've been doing back then was was a
problem you don't even have the
conviction to show your face on twitter
i mean and you think that what i did was
wrong i went up and i talked directly
i use the platform of tyrants
against them
and by the way so in my jihad series
especially episodes one through three
you'll see a lot of my
research against cve where i'm actually
refuting islamophobes
who are using cve research against
muslims
okay
so and i still support these arguments
i've always been against cve so it's
ironic how you don't mention these
things right
and those of you who have seen the ig
odd series you know what i'm saying is
true
so what did i do after that well after
all of my research and all these
lectures that i gave i was actually
invited to assist in one operation
it was actually some drama that occurred
before that where i was actually
shot at
i believe it or not i don't want to go
into the whole details but i was
actually uh meeting up with
malaysian police
in this one area
and uh we were discussing some things
and they wanted me to talk to some kid
and i actually got shot at okay so after
that event
um they thought that i was composed
enough to actually engage in field work
i did not get killed or hurt in any way
obviously
but
yeah that was interesting and so i was
invited to engage in a one
an operation where
there was reports of a smuggling ring in
thailand that was actually smuggling
weapons into malaysia to plan attacks on
malaysian soil it was actually by isis
affiliates based in thailand
this is a news report from the straight
times busted isis cell smuggling arms
into malaysia this is talking about my
operation
that i engaged in actually it's under
reported there's a lot of details
missing here because a lot of stuff
happened on the thai side and we can't
report that okay
so let me just read some of it malaysian
police have busted an isis terrorist
cell that smuggled weapons into malaysia
with the surrender of a cow farmer at
the thai border last week this is only
part of the operation occurred actually
afterwards prior to that
there was a
something that we did inside thailand
and some of you actually already know
about i've talked about it in other
streams
elsewhere
so
let's continue what exactly do they have
the cell had reportedly been smuggling
weapons into malaysia from thailand and
building up a stockpile for at least a
year to prepare for attacks in the
country and abroad the march arrests
were believed to be the first time the
malaysian authorities uncovered weapon
smuggling by militants linked to isis
security forces believe the cell had at
least five semi-automatic pistols a pump
gun and an m4 carbine assault rifle
actually there's a lot more than that
there were several several m4 carbine
assault rifles that we found
and especially even ak-47s we found
grenades and we found about 1200 pounds
of fertilizer ammonium nitrate okay and
i'll discuss what all that means in a
minute
yes and this is all working with muslims
this is not there's no non-muslims
involved here this is all muslims
okay so mr khalid said about another
five isis operatives were arrested last
week one was a retired military man who
channeled about 20 000 rm or 6475 to
isis in syria where his son had joined
the terrorist group so these aren't just
kids
just are saying you know they like isis
on twitter okay
these guys were smuggling in weapons and
they were planning attacks now you want
to know what attacks they were planning
well after all the data we collected
let me um
let me tell you what they were going to
do
so first off let me explain what an m4
carbine is this is an m4 assault rifle
this is a military grade weapon issued
to the u.s military
okay
uh this is commonly used by
army and marines u.s military
all right it's a very effective weapon
so these were not just some like random
kids getting some weapons together they
actually can get military-grade weapons
okay
they also had about 1200 pounds of
fertilizer they were gonna be utilizing
for a bomb
all right now for those of you who don't
know what fertilizer can do ammonium
nitrate remember that beirut explosion
that occurred
that's what ammonium nitrate can do
several thousands of pounds
of fertilizer
okay
now
the amount that they had wasn't that
amount
but it was quite significant enough to
hurt somebody so for example
300 kilogram bomb of ammonium nitrate
based bomb
uh
that was detonated in ankara in 2016
uh killed about 37 people
okay
and injured 70 others and it was based
in a car as a car bomb
so that's about 650 pounds worth of
fertilizer
now they had about 1200 pounds
now you're probably wondering well
what are they going to use it for
well from what we gathered based on
their text messages as well as written
records
and based on
their logistics of their movements et
cetera right we found out that they were
going to plan certain attacks in the
state of clanton the northern state of
canton in malaysia
now let me explain where that is so
here's the northern state of kalantan
okay and on this side where this river
is right this is thailand okay so they
were sneaking in
to the golok river
and they were going to start attacks
here
okay and here
this is only a few of them but let me
explain
why this particular spot that i've
marked here is significant so city
khadijah market
in kota baruch
okay
is where their first attack was going to
occur
and it's a significant place because
it's considered a landmark in
uh
in kelantan it is one of the most
popular market places in clanton and
they're also going to
attack somewhere else so let me explain
what they were going to do
this is
a marketplace it's actually a very
beautiful place all you see all these
sisters uh selling their vegetables etc
and you see yeah there's even a sister
there holding a child there's some kids
running around here it's nice right very
beautiful place
so their intention was to attack this
marketplace
on juma
on friday
because
and that's significant for a number of
reasons one because all of the men go to
the mosque on juma
so they were going to attack this place
when it was full of women and children
okay
so
let me tell you how they're going to do
that so this is the outskirts this is
near the the uh
the the back end
of the complex and here was where
they're going to bring in what they want
to do is they wanted to bring in pallets
of that
fertilizer okay
uh they were even discussing possibly
doing so through motorcycles i'm taking
in like small portions of you know
because a motor a typical moto can carry
about 350 pounds
so they were going to bring in it on
pallets and bring it to the center
complex
and they were going to place those
pallets on individual areas next to
these pillars here and we're gonna also
bring one maybe in the center here okay
now their intention wasn't to kill
everyone right they were going to
detonate
in a crowded area these pallets
fertilizer bombs
in specific locations to cause
what we call chaos
okay
and so they were going to kill a bunch
of people in the center here probably
all these women and children here if
they have been present they would all be
dead
because if you're pretty close if you're
within this range everyone in the center
here is pretty pretty much dead they're
all gone you can't recognize them okay
and they were what they were planning to
do what they were really going to do is
after this bombs exploded
people were going to rush out into these
hall areas here okay so the sides all
right
and they were going to stand at the
entrances with their m4 carbines and
they were going to shoot these women and
children and others
running towards the exits
okay that was their plan
all right
now while this was happening
sorry i have to
i actually visited
this place on a few occasions
you have no idea how many kids
okay um
so that was their plan
so while they were doing this
they were going to do this
another contingent
we're going to be attacking a very
famous mosque another landmark
not too far away called the muhammadi
mosque
and while this attack was occurring
they were going to position themselves
on all the entrances and they were going
to fire at all the incoming worshipers
outgoing worshipers that were coming in
okay
so this was what the plan the attack
that they were going to be planning
now we eventually arrested these
individuals before they could plan these
attacks
now let me ask you a question
had i been based in new zealand
and i had an opportunity to work with
special
with the authorities to investigate
this man here
taurent who was responsible for the
christ church shooting
which killed 51 muslim brothers and
sisters
he for those who don't remember he went
to a mosque to to mosque and he
slaughtered
numerous muslims in cold blood
if i had been told to stop him
would my work be considered halal
if the answer is yes
then we have an issue here
because
according to you muslim blood is cheaper
when it's being killed by other muslims
so you're basically claiming that it's
okay for me to stop somebody like him
from killing a muslim but if it's an
isis person it's okay
i can't do anything
we're not allowed to stop these people
at all
um
now if your answer is no that's another
problem that you're gonna have to answer
to to all your followers and friends
so just something to think about
i'm okay don't worry i just thought
about my daughter for a moment when i
when i imagined those kids
let me ask you a question as well here
here's a hadith
whoever defects from obedience to the
emir and separates from the main body of
muslims and dies in that state dies the
death of one belonging to the days of
jahalia and he was killed in the banner
of a man who is blind to the cause to
which he is fighting who gets flared up
with family pride and fights for his
tribe is not from my ummah and whosoever
from my followers attacks my followers
indiscriminately killing the righteous
and the wicked of them alike sparing not
even those staunch and faith and
fulfilling not his obligation towards
them who have been given a pledge of
security is not from me and is not my
follower
and yet you want to tell me that we
should have gira
for isis
that we shouldn't have done anything to
stop them from killing other muslims
this is the sort of gira these people
believe in that they would be able that
they would be willing to protect
terrorists people who actually wanted to
slaughter innocent brothers and sisters
and children
even when the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam himself disassociated himself
from them he did not have giraffe from
these people but yet you have girder for
them
what sort of gear is that
work with the kuffar
if i really was working with the kuffar
i would have allowed isis to do what
they did because that's what kuffar want
they want us to kill each other
so he goes on
he says you wrote an entire article
white washing your king's explicit ties
to a cve organization
sea post claiming that julio rivera
worked for the us army and advised
military generals to defend
syrians
okay so we're gonna see what this
evidence he has here by the sultanate
and i'm targeting the sultanate in this
as well very soon but first off let's
see what i actually did
right
so for i did not write an entire article
white washing akin's explicit ties to
any cv organization sea post
in fact what i did was that i wrote an
entire portion of an article
regarding the accusations against the
yakin institute
regarding cve
and therein i produced quite a bit of
evidence you can go read it down below
where i analyzed his arguments and i
provided sufficient evidence against
them including but not limited to the
fact that yakini institute has produced
articles explicitly bashing cve
explicitly refuting cve explicitly
undermining cve
okay
so
you completely ignored that you and
sultan it completely ignored those
things you even ignored the fact that i
defended dalia mujahid from being
from the accusations against her you
completely ignored those
and you focus basically only 10
of this particular part of the
refutation
i find that really fascinating how you
completely ignored the vast majority of
my refutation and focused on only two
little parts because well we all know
you can't answer them right
you can see the link down below
it's on my website
so
i did not whitewash anything but let's
look at his claims so he claims so
this whole thread by the sultan is
actually quite long it's actually five
threads in one
and
but i'm not gonna go through the whole
thing because there's only two main
points that we have to address to
showcase how nonsensical their views are
against the akin institute so here we
have an individual by the name of dali
akambo
who said what is your proof that your
key not only purposely and engage with
the established player in the cv and ct
industry because that is the crux of the
matter is that what you are alleging and
abu toby responds it says the following
here is the summary of the sultanates
threads the facebook photo is of the
director of a ctcv org linked to the
military facebook post shows uh uh
king's suit wanting to collaborate and a
linkid profile of someone who worked for
cve apparently okay so let's
let's look at
what these main points are so thank you
abbotope for summarizing this thread for
us because i don't want to go through
the whole thing it's really most of the
threat is just a bunch of waffling and
non-sequiturs and red herrings and
insults towards me anyway it's it's it's
basically if you had a guy with fish
wire and post-it notes you know in a
room by himself he's like they're all
connected bro that would basically be a
description of the thread
so let's go through the relevant points
okay
oops i'm going forward
so first of all let's see what sultanate
says about what he's saying about your
king
no one accuses you keen of taking cve
funding or supporting its framework but
there are reasons to believe it has
engaged in ct cve in some capacity okay
well first off
how is anyone working for you keen how
is your excuse me how is anyone working
for cv in yakin
or being supported by anything of the
sort if we don't get funding and we
don't support his framework
because if we explicitly go against this
framework and we're not receiving
funding how are we working with cve
or collaborating with them
that doesn't make any sense that's
already questionable right
so he had to water down his
uh statements against me i guess after
seeing my reputation
um
he goes if not then why does he you can
see future collaboration
with seapost an established player in
the cv and ct industry
he goes on to say we know omar suleiman
held a meeting and shook hands
with sea post director robert pate pape
in 2017.
where they promoted pape's book cutting
the fuse a book that for all intensive
purposes calls for a sustainable
strategy of using aaron naval power to
secure eos interest
so there's a there's a facebook post
where omar suleiman shakes
robert pape's hand
and robert page is pretty much well
known for
refuting the cve narrative
about you know how religion is tied to
uh terrorism okay
so
this is funny because we're gonna go on
in a second here so eventually he admits
after my refutations well that how
reassuring that no collaboration ever
materialized because
no collaboration ever materialized we
never material i mean we never worked
with them
um should one head be offered been
offered woody keane have refused in
principle let us look at the disgraceful
revision of yulia's work so this is
where so he basically admits that we
never collaborated that nobody ever
collaborated with seatpost
okay
that yakin
thought about it and then collaborated
didn't eventually collaborate with them
at all and this is the evidence that
ablotopia is using okay
so let me show you the argument they
basically have in a nutshell yaquin
institute thought about collaborating
with x
x is affiliated with cv apparently
jakeem did not collaborate with x
therefore yakin collaborates or supports
cve
this
is a non-sequitur okay this is a
fallacious argument
um
and here's here's the funny thing about
it
so
to give you a better understanding of
why this is ridiculous
he goes on to say innocent brothers and
sisters have had their lives room for
official police investigations etc i
agree with this statement and then he
goes on to say read uk cage's article
report in the science of pre-crime for
some food for thought so they don't
agree with pre-crime right
and what pre-crime is and i've read this
report i agree with this report by the
way i've used it i think in the past as
well in my own research
so
he they are against pre-crimes so
abattopian and sultan are against
pre-crime and what pre-crime is is that
you basically criminalize behaviors or
or thoughts of people prior to them
engaging in sort of like criminal
activities so this is what you think is
going to be a crim a criminal person so
you prosecute them you criminalize their
actions so for example cve and prevent
are known for going after muslims
and thinking they support terrorism just
because they become more religious
because they grow their beards out
because they pray a lot because they go
to the masjid um
even like having materials like oh they
own a magazine by isis or they're online
and they have an isis flag or something
and they criminalize this stuff now i
disagree with this
eminently like i i i cannot stress
enough how ridiculous
uh this pre-crime notions are
okay this this whole narrative all right
because even i would be accused of of
terrorism support because i mean i have
lots of works by isis that i study
okay so it's a thought crime thing right
now what's fascinating about this this
whole entire thread that the sultanate
has
produced
is that
his entire argument is based on
pre-crime based on the thought of
pre-crime his entire argument sounds
like somebody who works for cve or
prevent
okay
in other words he doesn't like pre-crime
but if it's against the akeen institute
then it's fine
you see kids i can make memes too
except mine are a lot more thoughtful
so
tea break
so it's fascinating how you're against
pre-crime but you're
trying to make someone guilty you're
making your keeness do guilty for
thinking about collaborating with
somebody
and it may not even have been
for
reasons that you think
right
so congratulations
uh you support creep pre-crime that is
your evidence is pre-crime
yes this is going to stay up afterwards
he goes on to say
oh by the way i want to mention
something about the cage as well they
wrote a post or a report recently i
think in 2020
which uh
gives their alternative to a lot of the
uh prevent and the the counterterrorism
laws
and i largely agree with this entire
statement here so let me read it out
loud and finally in responding to the
question of what we should do about
terrorism okay
we believe that we do not need
counter-terror laws to deal with acts of
actual political violence when they
occur acts of violence should be treated
as criminal law medals through pre-2000
legislation such as the offense against
the person act so cage is not saying
that we can't use western laws to
prosecute muslims engaged in terrorism
they're simply opposed to
counter-terrorism laws that currently
exist because they are flawed and are
not evidence-based
so in other words according to you guys
abu topian sultanate the cage
works with the kuffar
they go on to say
strictly strict liability offenses that
relate to possession of materials or the
dissemination of ideas should be removed
entirely from the statute books and any
crimes that incite violence should be
dealt with as crimes of incitement i
agree with this
frameworks exist for prosecuting crimes
of violence which precedes modern
counter-terror law and which are
adequate on their own terms so again
they're saying that english law
prior to 2000 is sufficient for dealing
with terrorism they're not saying we
should not prosecute terrorists muslims
okay so they are advocating for pre-2000
law
right the only thing they're objecting
to is contemporary laws
right so i'm sorry but they're not
exactly supporting your views here
crucially these concern themselves with
actual acts or provable intentionality
rather than crimes of thought so if you
can prove the intention to commit a
crime so for example what happened in
malaysia when they were planning to bomb
you know a marketplace and slaughter men
women and children
by smuggling weapons which by the way is
also a criminal offense
into malaysia to plan these attacks
that is called prove provable
intentionality
okay
according to you we're not allowed to do
anything
so
it's interesting how you use cage but
cage doesn't even agree with your
analysis
against me and your kid
so then he goes on he mentioned
something about uh julio working for the
department of defense when he first
reverted and and then eventually working
for sea post prior to joining akin
and i've gone over this
in my uh in my my review and my
refutation
and they essentially basically like
ignore
a lot of points in there to
smeary julio
but i'm not gonna go over all of those
uh i think that i've adequately
acquitted him but i just want to point
out that their whole art this is their
argument julio used to work with x and y
x and y are affiliated apparently with
cve
and the dod can couldn't be because he
worked with the dod from 2009 to 2012
and cve didn't start until 2011.
uh late mid to late 2011 so he actually
left like a couple of months after cbe
was implemented
so julio now works for yaquin institute
so he left c post and then a year later
he came to yaquin therefore yakin
collaborates or supports cve this is
their argument
because julio used to work for something
that they think is attached to cve
therefore
yukin and now he works for your
keynesian therefore jakeen works with
cve
this wouldn't even pass
this one pass in the shadia court
let alone a western court
again this is just pre-crime all over
the place
sultanate is behaving like a prevent
agent like a cve agent trying to connect
the dots
in order to accuse people of things
right
yes i have the fbi and speed dial but i
also have pizza hut on speed dial so
apparently i work with pizza hut
and abu topi
also supports fbi because he reports
muslims on twitter and twitter works
with cve
so
right
let's continue
so let's go to claim two we've already
destroyed claim one i think i've just
completely obliterated
claim one
i think i wouldn't even have to keep
going after this point i think your
reputation is gone abu toby i mean
you're done
at this point and the sultanate your
guys are just done
um but i'm going to keep going because i
believe
in overkill
i believe that
you
will only learn through this method so
i'm going to keep going
and i'm going to keep revealing things
about you and others okay
so
i go on to claim that he claims that i'm
a traitor to this ummah okay
he then says
he misquotes me he says they have
labeled me a traitor i didn't say
labeled
okay go back
can i go back
i said and being a traitor i never said
label okay so he misquotes me that's
that's beside the point
they have labeled me a traitor to this
ummah
where have me cyber mufti the sultanate
or one dao ever said this if you make a
claim substantial or is it clear lie
okay well first off why wouldn't you
consider me a trader to this if i indeed
did work
with cve
see so you've just revealed that you
actually lack gira
because if i found out somebody was
working with cve i would think they were
traded to this um because cve is prof is
is against the muslim ummah
it criminalizes normative islamic
behavior
so why don't you think that i was a
traitor to this ummah if you really
believe that i was working with cve
why don't you think i'm a traitor what's
wrong with you
so you've just exposed that you don't
actually have gyra because you don't
think that i'm a trader
maybe it's also because you you realize
that you'd be a traitor as well given
the fact that you and that you actually
report muslims to the authorities
so congratulations
now let's continue
so i say even going so far
as to support haitham scifideen who
openly declares me a monafic because of
said false allegations
and we already know
that uh that he has done this
now the said false allegations as you
know is that i work with cve right
now look what abutopy says next
so he quotes me properly and then he
says first it's quite clear that these
allegations are in fact true
for those who can't see this
he just said
that he never accused me
of working with cve now he's saying that
the allegations that i work with cve are
true
so which is it
this kid can't even remain consistent in
his own thread
so before he's like no i never accuse
you that now he's accusing me of this
he's saying that these allegations are
true
so which is it are they not true or are
they true did you not accuse me or did
you or did you actually accuse me so
you're revealing your own inconsistency
in the very same thread and it's very
clear that you can't even stay honest
for like two seconds
so let's continue
oh and by the way you do support uh so
here's the here's the actually working
with cve said false allegation the said
false allegations were working with cve
he goes on secondly i have never made
taklid of haithamsaya fadin and do not
agree with all his views as i have
explicitly mentioned several times and
thus i have never labeled you one after
well first off
i never claimed that you labeled miyamo
nafika said that you support somebody
who does
you're saying well i don't agree with
all of his views you don't agree with
all of his views well that's nice
that's nice that you don't agree with
all of his views
then why don't you come out and actually
say that why don't you actually come out
and make a thread about about haytham
sifa deen making tuck fear of me
right
because you apparently are upset when
people make tuck fear of you for
reporting people to the authorities for
reporting muslims to the authorities
but when he does it when haitham
scifideen makes tuck fear of me openly
you have nothing to say
why is that
oh abu topi privated his account
oh that's unfortunate
i was going to give him some options at
the end of this to save face
and to repent and apologize
so i guess he's already taken one of
those options
he's probably cleaning up his his
twitter as we speak
this is okay kids again it's hard to
digress this is why you don't get
involved in reputation culture
especially against somebody
who who essentially built refutation
culture
okay one of the old guard
all right these these these new
uh dies whatever they want to call
themselves don't hold a candle to what
we used to do
what we had to go through
and the arguments that we had to make
so you want to get involved
guess what now you're part of it how
does it feel being on the other end
let's continue
you may post this video we'll continue
so
even others have called you out
for you for this lack of standards
so when you are go so this is a brother
ahmed said this he says so when are you
going to make a thread criticizing
hathan for all his blatant tuck fear
against other people and tell others to
stay away from him because haitham said
in the takfiri
in fact he's he's for all intents of
purposes he's a khariji
okay he actually works alongside people
who are known criminals
like uh ahmed jabril
who was sent to prison for a number of
things including but not limited to
fraud
and uh abusing people
okay
so why aren't you posting threads about
these people it's because of tribalism
it's because of your machiavellian islam
you don't have principles you only care
about identity you only care if somebody
is attacking somebody you don't like
that's the issue
we're going to see more evidence of this
later as well
so let's go to claim four and this is
his last thing that he goes after me for
okay or officially speaking because
after that he waffles a lot we'll
discuss that as well
um
he said so this is what i claim it says
all of the individuals in question the
people that are discussed in the stream
that this comment is talking about have
either slandered other people's wives
sisters and mothers as glamour models a
derogatory term for a woman who sells
uh her body sexually for marketing
playboy and swimsuit models or openly
supported people who have without any
criticism towards them at all
now here's what abu toki says in
response
he quotes only half of my statement and
he says this is a complete lie if this
is true where in the where's evidence
for when have i ever labeled anyone a
glamour model
again let's look at the comment
i never accused abu-topi of saying this
of accusing of of uh claiming that other
women are glamor models this is what i
said all of the individuals in question
have either
done this or
openly supported people who have without
any criticism toward them so the latter
part actually applies to abu topi and i
mentioned this in the stream that was
deleted because the person who did make
these accusations was daniel
himself yes mookie khan this is the
fallacy of suppressed evidence and this
is something that these people do all
the time they delete
people's statements
to falsely accuse them of things this is
the same thing that daniel has done so
abu topi and sultan and others have
learned a lot from that daniel
okay so
as you can see he can deliberately leave
this part out now for those of you who
don't understand what or means
or is a conjunction that means use as a
function were to indicate an alternative
so
grammatically speaking there's no way
that i could have accused him of this
okay the the former part of that
statement right
so let's continue so let's look at this
accusation let's see if this accusation
is true okay about all the individuals
in question
so for example let's focus on daniel
hakikachu
what he said about glamour models
and before we go let's look at the
definition of glamour model
okay
the word glamour model
in british english and this should
appeal to abu toby since he's british
right he's uk citizen a woman who models
topless or nude for photographs
okay
another definition from oxford learning
dictionary
a person especially a woman
who is photographed wearing very few or
no clothes in order to make the person
looking at the photograph sexually
excited
okay
let's look at the us definition it's
very similar
and here's a from modelingadvice.com and
i had to block out the picture because
it was so revealing i'm sorry
says i'm getting a lot of young visitors
under 18 to the site so i won't go into
this too deeply glamour modeling is
modeling for photos with a sexual theme
this might be a simple cheesecake or
beefcake photo they can include bikini
sexy outfits and lingerie models so
let's keep going down
um
as one moves to greater states of
undress you move into the adult
entertainment industry
okay
and what is it what does it say after
that
with high-end men's magazines like
playboy and then on down to the low end
back alley magazines but it is the
internet that dominates this field and
is now loaded with all levels of sexual
model photos glamour modeling and its
triple x component is a very big
industry
top glamour models can make as much as
top fashion models so
this is the definition of glamour models
okay
now let's see
who daniel accuses of being a glamour
model remember these definitions
we go to his refutation on
muslimskeptic.com
glamour hijabi models everywhere
let's look at the the evidence that he
uses
to showcase that jaquin and others use
glamour models
this sister
is one of them
he accuses this sister
of being equivalent to a playboy
a swimsuit model
selling her body sexually
okay
let's continue
he accuses this sister
of being a glamour model so she's
equivalent she's in the same group as
playboy models and swimsuit models
okay topless women women who show their
breasts
let's continue
he accuses this sister of being a
glamour model
let's continue
he accuses these sisters
of being glamour models
it reminds me of the quran
indeed those who falsely accuse chase
unaware and believing women are cursed
in this world and hereafter and they
will have a great punishment on day when
their tongues their hands and their feet
will bear witness against them as to
what they used to do that day allah will
pay them in their in full their true
deserve recompense and they will know
that is allah who is the manifest truth
it's one thing to disagree with women
putting their posters up their pictures
up online
it's another thing to accuse women fully
covered sisters
of being equivalent to playboy and
swimsuit models let's talk for the law
right
and this is what the sultanate had to
say about my criticisms of daniel hakiku
using this statement about these sisters
and this is the thing that also
abhotopia supports as the genuine
criticisms of the keynesian are getting
buried amidst the relentless nitpicking
he claims that
me pointing out falsely accusing sisters
of being glamour models is nitpicking
nitpicking
this is nitpicking to them
okay
yeah
nitpicking and you know abu topi likes
to make himself appear as though he's
always defending sisters like oh
you can't say this about sisters i stuck
for a lot of stuff i'm here to protect
you
and yet he insulted and others believe
that
calling somebody out for falsely
accusing sisters
of being equivalent to playboy models is
nitpicking
okay sure you really care about sisters
all right
he goes on to now now all of these
claims are done so everything that i've
shown and almo topi and others did not
go against daniel after this they didn't
say anything they said absolutely
nothing
they haven't made a big threat about it
they didn't try to nuke his social media
accounts they didn't do anything they
didn't care
and uh so all of these accusations that
i've posted are true
i have not slandered or lied at all
about albutopia
everything as you can see was true and
it was proven by evidence
on the day of judgment it is very clear
who allah subhanahu wa is going to side
with in this regard
and it's not abu topi
okay i'm not speaking for allah i'm
speaking based on fact i'm speaking
based on my reputation
being proven
to still be intact that i'm the one who
has integrity here and the one accusing
me does not
and this is what these people do okay
they continuously lie
unashamedly
about others in order to boost
themselves up
all right tea break
but i want to keep going because as i
said i believe in overkill
okay and i want to keep going because i
because i want to show everyone exactly
what these people are like
so he goes on to waffle
and he starts throwing mud like crazy
because he wants something to stick all
right
and so here we're going to start dealing
with his waffling all right so this
reputation is not over
you know it's frankly it's just getting
started
he says i did not nuke muslim twitter
that was a discord server and he and abu
topi takes credit for nuking it
uh because i'm a kharijaite
and you and other mods claimed as you
and other mods claimed
well we didn't
we didn't accuse you of being
because
you nuked the server
we accuse you of that for other things
okay
which i think was the reason you nuked
the server but that's for that we're
gonna get to that in a minute
i nuked precisely because sisters and
others were being slandered by you and
other mods right
and then you show some pictures
um
so here's again he's using sisters he's
using sisters
uh to kind of like he does this a lot
online he uses sisters to sort of virtue
signal to show that he's white knights
to virtue signals to to make himself
look good i did it for the sake of the
sisters
i did if i nuked the server for the sake
of the sisters
mashallah look at me you know it's like
okay but yeah you didn't go about nuking
anyone else
when they called everyone glamour models
you're perfectly fine with that but you
know let's see exactly what he claims he
nuked the server for okay
you're gonna find out in a moment uh how
ridiculous this is
oh i'm sorry before we get into that
let's look at else what he does later on
in the thread he mentions my wife
and i want to read this to you to show
you how he uses sisters
i would have responded to this some time
ago had it not been for assad's wife's
pregnancy may allah protect her and the
children i don't go after the innocent i
certainly do not slander people in a
sexual manner and i condemn all who do
any of these first off what does my wife
have anything to do with this
she's not involved in this scene
she's not on twitter
you know what what does my wife have to
do with you delaying your slander of me
i had to hold off for the sake of
assad's wife
his pregnant wife
you were slandering me when she was
pregnant though i mean i showed you
post
in december my wife was pregnant in
december you didn't seem to care then
where you were slandering me about
working with cve
so i mean
this is not this doesn't even seem
relevant what's the purpose of bringing
up my wife
see so here he's using my wife to make
himself look honorable oh yeah i held
off because of assad's wife i i care so
much about his wife
yeah exactly silva's grayson i'm being
noble because you have a pregnant wife
i mean
you know you he complains a lot on
twitter about not being able to find a
wife
or you know and and how
brothers can't find wives you know
here's something that you should know
abu topi
from one man to a boy
if you want to get a wife first thing
you should do is be sincere because
women can pick up on that they can pick
up and pick up on insincerity quite a
bit
okay and secondly they don't like creepy
people
you know always mentioning
women to make yourself look good it
looks creepy
okay it's creepy all right stop it
and don't mention my wife again there's
no reason to bring up my wife in this at
all
okay
so let's continue with these pictures
so he shows these pictures so first off
let's look at this picture this is about
brother sajid
um
so this is during from what i understand
the context of this i remember i was a
muslim twitter this day and um
i was complaining about sajid
essentially
uh
accusing me of something that i didn't
believe in okay was on twitter it was
about sharia and the punishments for
apostasy and so i said he's and so i'm
bringing up this whole thing right
there's no there's no
slander here okay his followers were
making tough fear of me and i was upset
that he slandered me because that's what
i believed okay
this conversation continues and amin
comes in and says yes i'm on your side
it's just i know they can't wait for
this kind of stuff to misquote you so he
even recognizes that sajid was
misquoting me
and my twitter's now gone so i can't
prove any of this stuff that well but
this is the context of the discussion
and i said i already blocked him i said
his heart is either black is death or
he's too stupid to realize what he's
doing i still follow that
um it's not slander
okay you just didn't like the fact that
sajid got criticized right that's
for his own dishonest tactics
next apparently this is the slander of
sisters okay so noor
who is a moderator i guess uh said you
can have a private chat with all the
female chit chatters who are having your
coffee and doing
namima
so he's accusing the sisters of doing
she comes and says you're slandering us
and he says you're a cancer okay we
don't even know the full i don't even
know the full context of this whole
discussion or what happened to be honest
and the thing is we will never know the
full context of these discussions
because abu toby deleted the whole
server
and then snapshotted what he wanted to
snapshot without showing the full
context so we can't even go to the
server to prove what is actually done or
said
uh
so it's convenient for him to claim that
he did something for slander yet he
won't allow access to the evidence how
can you trust somebody like that
especially after we've already proven
that he's lied on several occasions
especially about me
so we don't even know exactly the reason
now i have an idea about why he did it
and i think it has a lot to do with
something else
oh yeah here's another thing he says uh
we should ban this girl and then they
they said she's extreme
um so you know apparently it's it's
wrong you want to nuke a whole server
for calling a sister extreme and saying
accusing a sister of doing namima
but
when daniel
calls innocent sisters glamour models
you don't want to nuke anything suddenly
you're just like
quiet about it which proves that you
actually have more fear of daniel hakiku
than you do allah
because if you had any consistency or
any principles whatsoever you would be
just as angry about that even worse but
you don't care
so yeah
don't give me this whole i want to
protect the sisters stuck for allah
and the reason we know that there's
probably something else going on here
about this whole muslim twitter thing is
because amin called him out when this
happened
so he's this i don't even know the
concept of the discussion entirely but
he's saying maybe you should ask abu
suja about how we respectively talked
about the whole thing for two hours but
you won't will you and he was uh
you he was he said i literally forbidden
the ill speech of abuja sujath my person
you know it and then as a result of
getting called out abu toby deleted his
tweet didn't apologize just deleted his
tweet and he does this a lot like i said
he deletes stuff when he knows he's been
refuted okay
amin goes on you're genuinely a snake
he's talking about here as you can see
and he says wallahi admit and repent for
deleting the chat from which you're
taking screenshots don't lie to me
you know it and i know it
i will not let this go until you repent
so he's recognizing that abu topi
deleted the chat and then taking
selective screenshots so we can't trust
this guy already okay goes on and
there's more context here
abu toby now pretends to be innocent is
using battle to defend his khadiji
behavior i.e the real reason he deleted
the chat
okay
the real reason that abu toby deleted
the chat is because he was trying to
cover his own tracks
all right that's the reason and i can't
go into more detail because we don't
have full evidence here but just want to
make this clear
he then goes on to say say to the snake
that takes screenshots and deletes the
chat so people can't go back to the
history to share the full context
exactly how can you trust somebody who
does that
he's trying to incriminate other people
yet he's the only one with access to the
evidence
you can't trust somebody like that sorry
so
i don't know what he's trying to do here
but it's obvious that it's not working
in his favor
and as i said he likes to delete things
okay
so when he was called out for slander uh
not to last year
somebody called him out said you'll be
answering he just deletes stuff he just
deletes things and
doesn't apologize doesn't say doesn't
take accountability for it at all he
just deletes things and acts like
nothing happened
okay so this is abotopi this is the
personality i'm talking about this is
the type of people who are engaged in
this reputation culture this is their
mentality it's a very machiavellian
islam that's based around defending
their own identities over defending
islam they use islam
for the sake of their identity not their
identities for the sake of islam there
are signs of nifak now that doesn't mean
that
they're very clear but they have signs
of nafak in that they are very
much okay
with deliberately lying about people and
hiding evidence that incriminates them
okay
so let's continue
we're not done yet
so this whole thing here is all virtue
signaling this whole entire display here
that he's trying to throw at us is all
virtue signaling okay
he goes on oh and assad you're the one
who talks about accusing people haram
sexual acts remember when we banned you
for publicly telling a teenage boy on
our server to divorce his hand i
implying he masturbates you're a
complete hypocrite
first off
i've been banned from the server so i
can't provide evidence to the contrary
but let me tell you my side of the story
i was wrong to say this to this young
man
i was very wrong and as far as i'm aware
i actually apologize and repented for it
now they're not going to show you that
they probably deleted it by now okay
because if i'm willing to apologize for
things that i didn't even mean to do
like with abu mahali and i post that in
my own server why would i not apologize
for this
i did indeed apologize it was wrong it
doesn't matter what the reason was this
was wrong for me to say i should not
have said this and this is me taking
responsibility for myself
this is me apologizing again and
repenting again for what i said
unlike something that's something that
you abu topi and sultanate and daniel
and others can't do
okay because i'm a man and i follow
islamic principles i make mistakes i
will apologize
i'm not ashamed to do that i don't
consider that a weakness i consider that
a strength
all right however i was not banned
because of this
the reason i was banned is because for
the nth time i had to come into your
server muslim chat and defend myself
against false accusations that i work
with cve in the fbi
and during this time
there was a lot of back and forth
between me and this young man and others
and your moderators don't do anything
about that
your moderators don't care about the
slander against me they've never banned
anyone or even uh punished anyone for
these things
and as a result
of this longer discussion
finally i think somebody tried to
apologize but basically it was like a
half-hearted like attempt to basically
cover for themselves and i said to the
moderators no you will do something
about this so it stops because it's like
the fifth time that i was accused
or something along those lines i don't
remember how much exactly but it was a
lot
and as a result of me challenging the
moderators
as a result of me rejecting that apology
because
nobody would actually do anything about
it there was no sincerity at all in that
server
i was banned and you know what's funny
about it you know what i was banned for
the reason
extremism that was actually the reason i
was banned extremism
another irony to to add on to this
refutation
so let's continue
okay so this is yeah i told this could
be kind of long huh
take a break
okay so you want to take a quick break
maybe a five minute ten minute break
everyone so uh any ques any comments so
far
about uh abu topi and and this
reputation
you're destroying abu topi's ego well
hopefully because uh then maybe he'll
start following islamic principles
i am drinking moroccan tea actually is
my favorite
i love you as well
i'm sorry about that i usually don't let
myself go like that but it was hard to
machiavellian means that you do
everything for the sake of your own
desires it's like your nufs basically
you're doing everything uh you don't
have any principle other than to get
power and influence
who's claiming that those plans were
fake to bomb the mosque they have no
evidence of that i was there i saw the
evidence
okay we we confiscated the weapons
what were they gonna use the weapons for
what to put up on their wall
why were they smuggling them into
malaysia
to possess those firearms is illegal
they were working with isis this is
nonsense anyone who claims is fake they
have no evidence for that
i was there
we risked our lives to stop these people
to protect our brothers and sisters and
those children from being killed and
slaughtered i mean how dare they claim
that it's fake oh because they want to
protect themselves
from criticizing me now that they
claimed that some of them claimed i was
a monastic others supported them who
claimed that i was a monafic they
claimed that i'm a traitor to this ummah
they claim they want to shame me for
working to stop these people stuff for
the law these people are pathetic
the government planned it they have no
evidence for that that's nonsense
they can't i mean this is see it
showcases their support for isis because
they can't
they can't they they don't want to be
incriminated
and remember again daniel's the one
who's supporting he supported this
threat he retweeted this thread so look
it so again i'm proving that he doesn't
have integrity either
so shall we continue
yeah everything is a false flag
everything everything that disagrees
with us is a false flag
they have no evidence for it
so let's continue um
he goes on to throw some more mud he
says and if you really are consistent
how about you condemn your king's
trollbots who continues to slander and
attack dh's wife to this day well first
off
i noticed this before i left twitter
that apparently there's jakeem bots
everyone who is criticizing daniel is a
keembot you know apparently um
because they can't handle that people
actually criticizing them so you see how
how
how uh sensitive they are to criticism
that they have to accuse people of being
bots okay
let's continue though um and apparently
i'm not consistent because i didn't
contend these pots for uh
for going after his wife slandering an
attack dh wife to this day well first
off abu topi unlike you i don't spend
all my time on twitter looking for
things to complain about
um in fact i don't even have a twitter
anymore so it's probably because i
didn't recognize any of this stuff
you know i actually have a job
and you know i take care of my wife and
my child
you know i don't i don't tweet every day
and make memes every day okay so you
know this is not so obviously i'm gonna
miss some stuff right
so i do apologize that i didn't come out
and condemn things that i wasn't aware
of before but let's look at exactly what
these accusations are okay so let's look
at the first one
okay so first off
let me get rid of this too because i
don't want to show this comment anymore
all right so
dan went to a mixed university and met
his wife there i bet he wasn't
complaining then l-o-l-o-l
okay well first off daniel did go to a
mix university and met his wife there
because he they both went to harvard
university which is a mixed university
all right
sorry about that
so uh i don't know how that's slander
apparently you don't understand what
slander is because a slanderer is when
you lie about somebody and try to harm
their reputation
so uh
yeah he did go to harvard a mixed
university and that's where he met his
wife because they both went to harvard
so that's not a slander
he then goes on to say
um when are you making a video about how
daniel's wife started an interfaith
group she also started an interfaith
group where she was part of an
interfaith group at harvard university
so that's also not a lie
so i don't see how this is evidence of
slander but okay
um let's continue
daniel huckiecoch's wife recently posted
that she went to an aquarium
uh
okay um i don't know how this is slander
because i don't understand the context
but you know if somebody accused me of
going to an aquarium i'd be like yeah
that's great i'm gonna take my daughter
to an aquarium when she gets old enough
i like going to the aquarium i don't
know why in aquarium
accusing somebody of going to an
aquarium is a bad thing
um
maybe that's a new thing among you guys
going to an aquarium maybe that's like a
simp thing to do i don't know
but for me going to aquarium is not a
bad thing so i don't know how this is
regarded as slander
or ruin somebody's reputation
so
maybe somebody can explain that to me in
the chat i don't know
but apparently going to an aquarium is
haram now or something
um
so uh let's continue
uh
so this is something that i do disagree
with first off the first part dh is just
a cloud chaser and he doesn't even know
arabic well that's true
for the most part so i don't think
that's part the other part is slander
though his wife dresses like a terrorist
stuff for allah
this is wrong
and this individual hakikuju versus the
world needs to repent and apologize
openly or at least in private to her for
stating this because it is wrong she's a
nikabi
this is completely wrong this is haram
to say
how dare you and i mean
i don't care
that you're against daniel hakika jew
versus the world even though i disagree
with him profoundly for his lack of
ethics
this is wrong to say
okay no sister who wears nikop should be
treated like this should be told that
they they look like a terrorist it's not
for the law okay so you need to openly
repent if you're watching this you need
to openly repent and apologize to him
now
okay
let's continue
this is more um
this is a little bit something i have to
explain because i had to actually look
this up because i don't even know what
was going on here
so
daniel accuses mahin islam and mahima is
not a bot as far as i'm concerned
because he actually runs the mad mamluks
or is one of the people who runs the
madman looks
um so i don't know how you accuse him of
being a bot
okay so that's weird
but anyway so daniel says why'd you
block me and whatsapp my hand right
before spreading old pictures of my
family lying about private conversations
and then mahin says because talking to
you is like spending wheels blah blah
and then this is something between them
too i don't know what's going on exactly
but i do know
what the issue was
that there were individuals who were
spreading old pictures of daniel's wife
not spreading actually they were just
revealing public pictures of her to
others
she is now in hikabi
and they were revealing pictures of her
when she was not a nakabi when she was
posting her pictures online for others
to see okay now i don't agree with this
in fact i was against this from day one
however
i understand the context behind it and
i'm partly not that sympathetic and let
me tell you why
so
first off
um khalid her name
uh supports daniel's accusations against
jaquin
uh and also his accusations against
those fellow sisters for
being glamour models accusing them of
being glamour models now what's
fascinating about this
is that um she was posted she had she
has public pictures of herself in the
past posting those having at the very
same quality as the ones that are being
accused of being glamor models
okay
so
it's evident that they were doing this
because they wanted to show the
hypocrisy of this family all right
so it's okay for you to go around
calling women glamour models but you
know if your wife has pictures in the
past up you know with her face showing
stuff then it's what we nobody can say
anything
so it's okay for you to
to to humiliate sisters openly who have
their pictures up
but if somebody does it to your wife oh
suddenly it's a problem
okay
um
and in the post he posted on may 11th he
said if you were looking for a wife miss
the ones who were posting glamour shots
on social media
use glamour hijabis so here's something
else that's fascinating
he's kind of incriminating himself as
well
because he married somebody who did this
he married a sister who posted now i
want to be very frank with you i have no
problem with what she did
you know she posts pictures of herself
smiling into a camera that's fine i know
i'm not going to sit here and condemn
her i'm not going to call her a
glamorous stuff for law i would never do
that i would defend her honor and i will
because i don't see anything wrong with
it you know if you disagree disagree but
i'm not going to sit here and accuse her
of something right
but he's saying basically saying giving
advice to brothers not to marry sisters
who put their photos on social media and
yet he married a sister who put her
photos up
in public for everyone to see
you know it's it's just somewhat
you know he's basically telling his old
self that he was wrong to marry his wife
and stuff for allah
and he doesn't seem to get it
he then goes on to make the same
accusations about uh these sisters who
who i showed you earlier use glamour
hijabis to advertise all their classes
some of these day youth he calls these
imams day youth okay that's very
significant
even share glamour picks up their own
wives and daughters every eid all right
um
he's also basically insulted all of
indonesia and malaysia because that's a
cultural trait to show pictures of your
family during eid to give eid greetings
so apparently every single man in
malaysia is now a daiuth
and that's significant to say because
diuth so let me remind you this is these
are the sisters he claims are glamour
models these are the same type of
pictures that his own wife had online
okay
remember he claimed that these women are
equivalent to playboy models
this is apparently equivalent to a
playboy model
playboy models that's that's
okay
so abu topi
is more concerned about
brothers claiming that sister went to an
aquarium than he is about glamour models
so it's okay to say it's wrong to say
a sister went to an aquarium but it's
okay to say that these sisters are
glamour models let's go for the law
yeah okay
so let's continue
and about day it's a very significant
thing to say about somebody
three persons will be not this is a
hadith this is
uh
three persons will not be looked upon by
allah almighty on the day of
resurrection one who disobeys his
parents a woman who imitates men and the
man who allows his woman to fornicate or
dius
okay
so he's essentially arguing that anyone
who has a woman's picture posted online
is a diuth
a husband or a brother or a father
so all the sisters say he showed
apparently their why their their
husbands who their husbands their
brothers
their fathers their daif he's claiming
that they're gonna go to hell
and yet
when people showcase his hypocrisy oh
suddenly are stuck for allah how dare
you
a stuck for allah well maybe
you wouldn't be so offended if you
actually had standards
right
if all of you had standards but you
don't
so let me bring this up
religion is sincerity this is a sahih
hadith religion is sincerity religious
sincerity religion is sincerity they
said to whom all messenger
he said to allah to his book to his
messenger into the imams the muslims
into their common folk
your lack of sincerity is evidence of
your lack of religion
your lack of sincerity is your evidence
of your lack of religion your lack of
integrity is evidence of your lack of
religion you can sit here and claim
all day long and about how you hate the
liberals and everything but you behave
just like them because they are also a
religion of convenience
they also pick and choose
what they want to follow just like you
so you may have different conclusions to
the liberals but you behave just like
them in their methods
which is what i've been saying this
whole time
he goes on to say
like i said i'm not done yet
assad has also incited people to dox me
on his live streams and also incited
violence against me
unlike assad we don't believe in
pre-crime well actually you do believe
in pre-crime because you're accusing a
keen institute of working with cv based
on pre-crime narratives
so he's talking here about well first
off let's address the inciting violence
in this last stream that i deleted i
also stated that somebody could go smack
around abu topi and these other people
because i was responding to the banter
on a stream where they were saying that
somebody should smack some sense into
them now nobody who says that anyone who
ever says that doesn't mean it literally
okay so i was just playing around there
was no i mean he's right now he's acting
like abdullah sameer
you know abdullah samir hears one thing
like this he's like i was
talk for allah you know
he doesn't say that
he says oh my god the muslims are trying
to kill me oh my god yeah god you know
so he's he's doing the same thing as
abdul samir here
and he's trying to criminalize my
statements
which is ironic because you know he's
perfectly fine defending an isis person
uh for planning an attack
you know by acute by shaming me for
stopping it you know but uh you know
whatever
um
and then he goes on to say that i tried
to dox him and i never claimed i never
tried i never said that people should
dox him that's ridiculous
um i did say that somebody should find
out who he is right and the reason i
said that
and by the way there's nothing wrong
with that
unless they can provide something from
the quran and sona that somehow it's
wrong to know who you really are
so um
so can so if we continue
um
sorry i was just hearing something
outside
so i want to find out who they are
because i know for a fact these people
leave live double lives okay because if
you see
how they behave online
they're completely inconsistent right
they don't have any integrity right so
these people live double lives that's
why they're anonymous it's not because
they're scared for their lives or
anything i mean if security services
wanted to do something they could find
them regardless if somebody docks them
or not right it's not because they're
scared for that it's because they're
scared of what people will find out
about their real lives
see abu topi
is like
a video game avatar
right
uh like somebody who plays world of
warcraft it's like an avatar in world of
warcraft okay and behind the avatar is
the real person right and the real
person and abu topi the avatar are not
the same thing they're not the same
person okay they never were
all right because you can see it in the
way that they behave right
it's the same way with haitham saif deen
right hadam sai fadin is not really who
he is online in fact he's a pediatric
mental health professional a pediatric
surgeon or assuming a pediatric
psychologist
who works
near toronto
and he knows that his views are shown on
you know if somebody attaches his views
to his real person
like all his views about hating kufar
and things like this and supporting
against tagut and all these things he'll
probably lose his job
right he'll probably lose all of his
clients he'll lose his license
right so i mean
haitham saif deen has more conviction
for his paycheck than he does for the
dean
so these people don't these aren't real
the way that they present themselves
online this is not real
okay
so that's why they remain anonymous
because they don't want people to find
out what they do they don't want people
to find them in real life
so then he continues on
okay we're almost done we're almost done
this repetition is almost done i promise
it is rather interesting that i continue
to live in assad's head rent free and
are we that threatening to you that you
must do your best to slander us as penis
as aq supporters right
well first off
you're not threatening to me because if
you were threatening i wouldn't respond
to you
i'm responding to you because you're not
threatening all right
number two
it is rather interesting that i continue
to live in assad's head read free yes
abatopia let me admit right now you live
in my head rent free but let me explain
what that means because you think it
means that you're important
that somehow you live in my head because
i'm obsessed with you because you know
you're so important to me even though i
talk about other people more than you
like abdullah sameer and stuff right
let me tell you how you live in my head
rent-free you live in my head rent-free
the same way that my spoons
and my forks and my knives my utensils
live in my kitchen
rent free
you live in my rent my head rent-free
the same way that my toilet
you know my uh toilet paper my bidet
lives in my bathroom rent free
you live in my head rent free the same
way that my car lives in my garage
rent-free in other words
there's like a little box in my head a
little tool box where i pull you out
whenever i need you
to use you for something
as an example
you don't live in my head rent free as a
guest you live in my head rent free
as a possession
as a means to an end that's where you
live that's how you live
so yes you do live in my head rent free
because i own you
you get it now
okay
he goes on to say
how about you respond properly to the cv
allegations against yakim without
whitewashing
right
why didn't whitewash you just ignored 90
of the refutation and focus on two parts
by implementing by utilizing
pre-crime
method methods to accuse the akin
institute
of working with cve so how about you
respond
to my actual refutation instead of
ignoring
everything that i've written
okay continue
he goes on to say
oh and julio isn't the only one with
links to cv more is to come inshallah so
he's actually admitted here that he's
actually trying to reveal more stuff and
it seems to me that he is
working alongside daniel uh and the
muslim skeptic team
so they're going to try to reveal more
stuff here i think in the near future
but let me be honest if this is the
quality of your work son
uh
i don't expect much
i mean i eviscerated the last article
you guys revealed in the king institute
you don't think i'll do it again
you are easy the first time you're easy
now and you're going to be easy in the
future
if i can take out 12 of you guys in one
shot i can do it again okay so don't i
mean don't you shouldn't even waste your
time because
i'm going to make an example out of you
again all right
but he goes on he says but
let it be known publicly that hassan ali
is a liar and a slanderer and should not
be trusted well by the evidence it's
clear
that
i can be trusted because
as proven by all the evidence that i've
shown
you're the liar and you're the slanderer
right
so all of these claims that he's
mentioned that i lied about
that lied about him are in fact true
has abutopia at all falsely accused me
on numerous cases of working with cve
and being a traitor to this ummah even
going so far as to support hateful
seifidin who openly declares me as a
monopoly because of said false
allegations
yes has have all the individuals that i
mentioned throughout previous streams in
this stream
either slandered other people's wives
sisters and mothers as glamour models or
orally supported people who have without
any criticism towards them at all
yes
finally he says this if assad does not
cease retract his lies against me and
repent may allah deal with him for allah
is most just yes he is most just but
he's not going to be dealing with me son
not in regards to this issue
because you've revealed yourself to be
the one who's dishonest
and presenting a false narrative
so
i think you should probably apply this
to yourself and stop projecting your own
insecurities onto me
and i'll leave you with two more quotes
to show you how close how how funny
these guys are in terms of their
inconsistency and how they actually
represent the very liberals they're
attacking
he goes on to say the deviancy of this
is a different tweet altogether the
deviancy of the
is not comparable to the deviancy of
secular liberal panders in the west
you will find the latter often misquotes
or lies in order to defend the
ridiculous position well first off i
don't agree with that i think the
colonies are just as bad or if worse
but he says the latter the liberals
misquote and lie in order to defend
their ridiculous positions but that's
exactly what you do
because you have a liberal mindset
next
another tweet charlie hebdo is the
greatest manifestation of what secular
liberalism is truly about why
freedom from what accountability because
it promotes freedom from accountability
but that's exactly what you promote by
deleting all your tweets by never
apologizing by never calling your own
people to account through because of
your tribalism you do exactly the same
thing as the liberals you accuse you
refuse to be held accountable for your
own sins and your own errors
so how are you any different
from the liberals that you condemn
you're not you are a liberal you just
have different conclusions
and that is the presentation
my friends and family
now before ending this refutation
i want to mention something
i want to give abu topi a way out i want
to provide him an olive branch so i'm
going to go over
four possible options he can take for
this refutation because i'm going to
leave this up
number one
let's go over the bad the bad options
first number one about opi
you can delete your account or private
your account which i think you've
already done
okay
but that would be a very cowardly move
and it would showcase that i actually
have stuff on you
okay so i wouldn't do that
so i would reverse your decision right
now
option number
two option number two
you can
ignore this which is not going to work
for you either because i want everyone
in this chat right now or anyone to
share this video on twitter
and pr and also against him
i want you all to hold him to account
okay
number three you could try to respond to
it
but that's going to be the worst
decision you make
because
that's not going to happen son you can
try your best
but
i have destroyed every possible loophole
you could ever possibly try
there is no way you're going to be able
to respond to this with any level of
sincerity
or truth attached
okay you're going to make yourself look
worse trust me
so don't do it masked error before you
failed to do that
so are going to have a cod failed to do
that griffix
crouton tea all the people that i've
refuted over the years they've all
failed you will be the same way trust me
son
okay don't try
so
after all that's done let me give you
the actual option that i think you
should take
okay
here's the option
you need to publicly apologize to me
on twitter
and repent openly and you need to pin
that tweet for one month
okay
because i think i think that's very
gracious by the way because you've been
you've been slandering me for more than
a month
all right
so that's number one okay number two you
need to produce a thread condemning
daniel
for calling those sisters glamour models
and of thread condemning haitham saif
deen
for making fear of me
you and salah and uh the sultanate by
the way you both do these things
number three in response to you doing
this
in response to i'm going to offer you
something in response to doing this
i will take down this video i will
privatize it i won't delete it yet
because i can't trust you but i will
privatize it and i will accept your
apology and i will come to your defense
if people come after you
i will do that
because i'm a man of honor
next i will invite you to my discord
channel
and i will teach you how to properly cr
to properly think critically
i will teach you
how to do download properly and how to
do reputations properly and i will do it
for free
i will take you in as my student
okay and i will do it for free
in other words i won't charge you for it
like daniel does
so those are my that's the final option
okay
if you want to take it
and if you are a man of integrity in
principle as you claim
you will do these things you will you
will take that final option
so
i think i'm being very generous and i
mean what i said at the end i wasn't
doing that to insult you or to humiliate
you because i'm not like that i'm
legitimately want to teach you i
legitimately want to turn you into
somebody who can actually do good for
this ummah
but if you really if you don't want to
behave that way
then i'm sorry
you know i guess this video is going to
stay up
so take
those things into consideration take
what i'm saying in consideration and
please do as i ask for your own sake for
the sake of yourself and if you don't
it's no skin off my back because at the
end of the day i get your good deeds at
the day of judgment
so
regardless of what you do i still win
so please swallow all of the
all of the uh pride that you have and
actually think about islam think about
your principles don't think about your
ego don't think about your identity for
once think about islam what is the right
thing to do
i'm offering you a chance so i expect
you to take it inshaallah
anyways thank you very much for have for
watching i appreciate it uh greatly
please uh support this video if you can
comment please tell me how the
refutation was inshallah and i hope to
speak with you all soon i have to go
take care of my baby and uh because i've
already spent too much time on this guy
and i do hope that he makes the right
decision
too